For this next section, we're going
to dive very deep into our cameras, in particular,
talking about the difference between our game camera
and our cinema cameras.
So a game camera is traditionally
what the player uses to view the world,
to play through the world.
When you play a game, you are possessing that character,
or if you're doing a third person or top down,
that camera is the camera into the world
and what the player sees through.
So traditionally, we use these game camera actors.
In fact, if I go back to the editor,
I'll kind of work over in this section here,
I'm going to go up to my windows, Place Actors,
and I'm just going to simply search for camera.
And you see here is our camera actor.
And I'll move this up so you see there's our camera actor.
Move this up and it does, in fact, look blue.
So taking just a quick look over in our Details panel
here, you'll see that we have our camera.
And for the camera settings, it's very basic.
We have a projection mode.
So go perspective or orthographic.
Our field of view, which you should be familiar with.
Obviously, if it's smaller, it's a tighter field of view.
And if we go up, it's much wider.
And we have our aspect ratio.
As you can see, as I change this,
I can make it wider or skinnier.
Now beyond this, we have a few camera options
and we have the ability to do some post-processing.
Now we're not going to cover post-processing in this class.
But the important thing to note here
is that we don't really have a lot of traditional cinema
controls that we'll see here in just a second
with our cinema camera actor.
And that is by design.
This camera is meant to be a very basic camera because,
again, in traditional games, we're not really
looking to overload a lot of post-processing effects
or special different on-screen visuals.
We simply just want a camera that's looking into our world
that the player can play through.
Now going to take a note real quick,
we have this constraint aspect ratio.
We'll talk about this in a little bit,
but just know that it's within our Details panel.
All right, so this is going to be just our regular game
camera.
Go ahead and press Escape.
And I'm going to drag in a cinema camera actor.
Let's go ahead and pull this up.
And you notice that the visuals are different.
Here we have our gray camera posed as a blue.
And if we go over to our Details panel,
you'll see that we actually start
to have a lot more control, which all of these controls
are intrinsically tied to real world counterparts
to traditional cameras and cinematography.
So for example, we have our film back.
I'll expand these out.
And you see we can start playing with sensor widths.
There are some presets here, but know
that you can always override these to do custom.
But these are just some presets
based off of, again, traditional film,
traditional cameras, and the way they operate.
Our lens setting, you'll see that we actually now started
to talk about f-stops.
We're talking about focal lengths.
This is important to understand, too,
that if you've ever looked at that rich cinema feel,
we've got this beautiful depth of field.
In fact, let me take the camera, and we'll move it
down.
And you'll see we're starting to get some of that.
In fact, let's go ahead and just focus in on this little
bush up here.
So the bush is slightly fuzzy.
And then it starts to get a little bit more in focus.
And right now, in fact, if I turn on,
I'm going to go back to our Focus Settings here, turn on
our Draw Debug Focus Plane.
And as I drag this in, we should
see it come into focus.
So this is going to be where the camera is focusing.
So if I zoom in to put it right in the middle of this
little plant here and uncheck it, you'll see now the
actual plant is in focus, and the background is blurred.
So it feels very cinematic, feels like a real camera.
And that is by design.
So without going through all of these various different
settings within the Cinema Camera, it's important to note,
again, from a very just high-level, simplistic
explanation of this, is that our blue camera is going to be
a very simple camera, and then our gray camera is going to
be our very cinematic.
So hopefully that makes sense.
So inside of our sequence, traditionally speaking,
we're going to want to use this Cinema Camera
because, again, we're going to want to take advantage
of all of those really high details.
Now, you could use a player camera.
That's completely fine.
But for the Cinema Camera actor, it's going to allow us
to do, again, those depth of field.
It's going to allow us to do focus tracking,
a lot more controls that, typically speaking,
we're going to want to have
when building out our sequences.
So a couple things to note, as I had mentioned,
one of the important things is this
constrain aspect ratio.
So it's important to note, I don't know if you've played
a game before, and you're playing your game,
and let's say that you have an ultra-wide,
you have a much wider field of view.
And if a game has been made to where you go
into that sequence and you have these black bars
on the side, that's probably because the sequence itself,
which we can specify the ratio within our camera,
was probably set up as a 16 by nine.
So if you use your camera and you uncheck
constrain aspect ratio, for users that have
a non-16 by nine ratio monitor,
or whatever they're viewing it on,
it'll actually allow it to stretch to the full length.
So just keep that in mind in your back pocket
as you're building these.
It's a very simple button that we can,
or toggle that we can just check on or off
to be able to get rid of those black bars on the side.
We talked about our film back.
So again, this is gonna be our sensor,
our width and height.
We talked about various different lens settings,
our focus settings.
Now, if I jump over to our sequence real quick,
and I'm gonna go ahead and stretch out our timeline here.
You'll see that we have a couple different shots.
So we have this one where it's following,
and then we have our second shot,
which you'll notice is actually tracking with the player.
And that's because we've enabled look at tracking
with our camera to track this particular character
as you move across the screen.
And then here, you'll see,
we also have some various different lens settings.
Our focus is directly on this NPC,
for lack of better terms.
And you'll see this blurred in the background.
And again, that's something that we can take advantage of
by using a cinema camera,
as opposed to just a regular camera.
And then finally, we talked briefly that
within the cameras themselves,
we do have post-processing effects.
Now, something just to throw in your back pocket
to keep in mind is,
I don't typically recommend
using post-processing on the camera,
but rather using a post-processing volume with that.
The advantage that you have there is,
say for example, that you set up a camera
with a specific lens ratio, a specific F-stop, right?
Like a camera that you want to use quite often
throughout an entire sequence or multiple sequences.
By decoupling your post-processing volume,
it means that you can swap in different cameras
or you can change things out as needed.
And you're not locked to just having
those post-processing settings on that one specific camera.
So just keep that in mind
that you can still do all the same post-processing effects
through a post-processing volume,
but as a handy feature,
we have some of those post-processing things
directly on the camera itself.
So just keep that in mind.
The other thing to keep in mind here is that,
as we're building out our sequence,
we can have multiple cameras.
In fact, if we jump back over to our sequence,
you'll see here actually we have our three cameras.
So CCA1, O2, and O3.
In fact, these exist in our world.
So let me go ahead and just delete
the example cameras we have here.
So I'll select my CCA1, press F to frame,
and you'll see there is that camera.
CCAO2 is down here.
So you see that we can have multiple cameras
within our scene.
Now within each of these shots,
we can actually associate those with a particular camera.
So if I right click and go to properties,
you'll see here, camera binding ID.
Now fun fact, pro tip here,
if you've ever opened up a sequence
and you get this red bar around there saying
the camera binding has been de-associated,
but you're looking at your scene and you're like,
but wait, my camera's in the scene, what's happened?
It happens occasionally.
All you need to do is go back into the shot itself
and rebind your camera and all the keys
should still be there and it should work like normal.
So just a couple other cameras to keep in mind.
We do have the scene capture component 2D,
which is a special type of camera that allows us
to essentially capture our scene
and render what is being fed into that camera to a texture.
In fact, this is one of the cameras that used
if you're trying to capture like HDRI cubes
within your editor.
Yes, that is the thing that you can do, it is awesome.
And you use this camera essentially to be the eyes
in the world, the position, and then you will capture
whatever it's seen and render it to a texture.
We also have a cinema capture component 2D.
Now this is new as a caveat,
it is in beta mode as of 5.3.
So just kind of keep this in mind,
but it essentially just extends the capabilities
of the capture component to allow for a few other
nice visual effects such as our post-processing,
OCIO and lens distortion.
And then we also have a VCam actor.
Now this is outside of essentially what we're doing
for this particular class,
but as I had mentioned in our plugins,
there are different things that we can use.
So say for example, we can use the Apple AR kit
to capture your face via motion capture.
We can use motion capture suits as well.
And one of the other really cool features is
by leveraging an Apple device such as a iPad or an iPhone,
we can actually transmit the location,
rotation, position information of that iOS device.
Also works for Android, but iOS is more supported.
We can translate that information directly in engine
to a camera actor, in this case using a VCam actor
through the Live Link plugin.
This is an amazing tool to use.
So if you are familiar with traditional film,
one of the things that makes something feel more natural
as opposed to synthetic is the camera movement, right?
Traditionally, when a film is working, right?
It's either on a operator's shoulder
or it's on a dollier track.
And there's these very subtle movements that you get,
whether it's from the mechanicals of the camera itself
moving along the track or the operator's slight movements
that we've grown accustomed to
as we've watched film over the years.
All that to say, so you can use a VCam actor
coupled with, say for example, an iPad,
and actually record all of that information
and essentially do the camera movements with that iPad
and you see it in real time.
It's amazing tool, absolutely worth looking into.
We're not gonna do this for this class,
but just keep that in mind.